the philadelphia eagles technically
remain in first place in the nfc east
but carson wentz has become a pin
cushion for local and national criticism
a far cry of the guy that he was three
years ago when he was taking the league
by storm in his second season he was the
original second year quarterback to take
the league by storm before patrick
mahomes lamar jackson kyler murray it
was carson wentz until the torn acl he
is nothing like he was then here's coach
doug peterson this morning during his
weekly visit to wip radio in
philadelphia
at that position
this late in the season when that
happens sometimes people take that as
okay we're kind of looking into next
year or you know preparing for next
season whatever it might be and giving
some of these young guys an opportunity
to play that's not the case jalen
jalen is preparing himself each week to
play and that's what a backup
quarterback should do
my perspective is that we have to get it
fixed with carson wentz and we have to
we have to that's where my trust and my
faith lies and then we can get it done
and
and so that's
that's where i'm at but i by no means am
i saying that that i don't have trust or
faith in jalen
it's it's a matter of having the getting
the corrections done with carson
look the reality for the eagles is very
simple it's very clear they've made
their bed they are now trying to fall
asleep in it they are trying to get the
most out of carson wentz they have no
choice they owe him 25 million fully
guaranteed for next year they can't do
anything with carson wentz unless they
want to pay him to not play for them
they're not going to be able to trade
him unless they do a brock osweiler type
thing pay part of the salary or throw in
the draft pick
with carson wentz in his contract no one
especially next year with a salary cap
that's expected to be 175 million
because of the pandemic no one's going
to take on that obligation of 25 million
in cash to carson wentz not based on how
he's currently playing
and there's always someone out there who
thinks i can fix a guy i don't know that
anyone is going to think they can fix
carson wentz to the point where they
would take on that big of an obligation
so they're stuck they're stuck plain and
simple they have to make it work
they have a car that isn't running and
they can't trade it in they've got to
keep working on it they got to change
the tire they got to put in a new
alternator whatever an alternator is
they got i know what an alternator is
they got they got to do whatever they i
think they have to do whatever they can
to get the car running period so there's
no reason to even have the conversation
shireen they're stuck with the guy they
have to keep trying to make chicken
salad
yeah and you talk about fixing the
problems mike that was one thing that
doug peterson said today we feel like we
can fix him well if you feel like you
can fix him why haven't you fixed him
yet because i mean we're near the end of
the season we're past the halfway mark
if you're going to fix this guy you
better fix it now because you could win
the nfc east and you're going to go get
embarrassed in the first round of the
playoffs and everybody's going to be
saying the same thing they have
continued to say about carson wentz this
is a guy who's never won a playoff game
and perhaps will never win a playoff
game for us but he's under intense
pressure now and if he thinks that he's
under intense pressure now it's only be
ratcheted up in the off season when he
goes into next year and they can't do
anything with him and you're right
they've made the bed and this is what
they have and they better figure this
out whatever way they have to figure it
out whether it's playing jalen hurts a
little bit more and maybe some type take
some hill type situations or whatever
and look doug peterson is a creative
mind you got to figure it out even if
it's throwing in trick plays like the
cowboys did against them with ben
dinucci a few weeks ago pulled out every
stop maybe it's that throw everything at
them including the kitchen sink but
they've got to figure something out if
they're going to be a competent team
heading into the postseason if they
indeed win the nfc east
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports